imagine never being able to dream of
landing on Mars or traveling to Saturn
not because it's impossible to get there
but because they didn't exist because
earth was the only planet in our solar
system
what would the night sky look like where
would the earth be located and how would
humanity evolve this is what if and
here's what would happen if earth was
the only planet in the solar system the
other eight planets in our solar system
are just pretty to look at or something
that we strive to travel to one day even
though they're billions of kilometers
away they've played an essential role in
life here on earth
so what would happen if they never
existed
each planet in the solar system played a
vital role in the development of Earth
billions of years ago and they continue
playing a vital role in keeping earth
safe today for example take the
placement of every single planet they
all have their own little space in the
galaxy and that's not by accident our
planets work together to keep each other
in place for example if Mercury and
Venus cease to exist earth might drift
closer to the Sun and if Jupiter or
Saturn disappeared instead of getting
closer to the Sun and the earth might
drift further away from it this would
cause a number of issues for us
earthlings
right now we're lucky enough to live in
what scientists call the Goldilocks zone
they call it that because earth sits in
the range of orbits around the Sun that
are just right to sustain life if earth
were to move closer to the Sun it will
get a little bit hot we might burn to a
crisp
the farther away we get the more the
temperature would drop earth would be
too cold to sustain life the position of
Earth in our solar system not only
affects life but everything that happens
on our planet it affects our seasons the
length of our days and how long our year
is but unfortunately the time we wake up
will be the least of our worries with
earth being the only planet in our solar
system there's no telling where it might
end up we could be all the way in the
back where Uranus and Neptune used to be
or somewhere right up front where
mercury once was it's safe to say that
no matter where we end up if it's not
the Goldilocks zone there's a pretty
good chance there wouldn't be any life
here on earth if life did form somehow
it would definitely be aquatic that's
because without any other planets
keeping us in check Earth's gravity
would be severely different when we say
no other planets we mean no moons either
the moon's gravitational pull is
responsible for the tides here on earth
without it our waters would remain still
the oceans wouldn't rise or fall they
would just stay where they were
so really earth as we know it wouldn't
exist if there were no other planets
there's virtually no chance that
humanity would be living today but what
if instead of the planets never existing
in the first place one day they suddenly
disappeared well apart from Earth
violently moving around not knowing
where to go we'd also have another huge
issue to worry about asteroids it's
clear that every planet is critical to
life on Earth if just one planet
suddenly disappeared a number of issues
would go along with it there are two
planets that have a very special role in
keeping Earth safe Jupiter and
that's because while earth is hanging
out thriving with life Jupiter and
Saturn are getting beat up by millions
of asteroids flying through our solar
system there are hundreds of millions of
asteroids that are trying to kill earth
luckily we hardly see any of these and
that thanks to Jupiter and Saturn
because of their enormous size and
gravity they do an excellent job of
pulling asteroids into them so that they
never make it to earth with these
planets gone earth would be bombarded by
asteroids not good in case you've
forgotten a single asteroid hit Earth
millions of years ago wiping out the
entire dinosaur population so this would
end up being pretty bad earth would soon
be covered with massive craters and once
again life would cease to exist luckily
you won't have to worry about any of
this you can rest easy knowing that
earth sits comfortably in this perfect
little spot in the universe where we can
all live and thrive another thing you
don't need to worry about is what would
happen if the earth lost oxygen for five
seconds but it is fun to think about it
anyway so we'll leave that story for
another what-if
you